with over 500 sessions at next 19 it's
understandable that you might have not
seen them all so if you means more than
data warehouse with bigquery where the
bigquery lead Jordan T Gani shares how
we're transforming bigquery into the
data warehouse of the future don't worry
because this is the rewind you might
already know that bigquery is our
enterprise data warehouse built for the
cloud it can easily store exabyte of
data as well as run sequel queries over
petabytes of it everything is encrypted
durable and highly available and these
are some of the features that make
bigquery really unique it's fully
managed and server life it handles
streaming data to provide real-time
analytics it has built-in support for
machine learning and G analysis and high
speed memory bi engine was just added
for instant interactive dashboards and
of course during the talk we had quotes
from industry analysts and customers
that can attest to all of these as well
as petabyte scale interactive demos but
let's focus on the main message of this
talk how is Google cloud putting all of
this together to build our vision of
what the data warehouse of the future
should look like let's start with the
first two elements a data warehouse
should handle storage and compute and by
that I mean the ability to collect all
the data you need to have together and
the ability to analyze it and combine it
at any scale in fact one of our
customers is a story more than 250
petabytes of data in bigquery and others
have run a single query over more than
five petabytes to pull this off you
really want your data warehouse to be
truly serverless you get to decide on
your data and the queries you want to
read on it while we take care of running
everything else behind the scenes and
what's the magic behind the scenes
before this architecture that separates
storage from compute and a petabyte
network connecting both sides go
but that's not enough a modern data
warehouse should be able to work with
real-time data to prove this during the
talk jordan ran a better flow pipeline
generating data out of more than 600
cpus as you can see here these nodes
were generating more than 2 gigabytes of
data per second and he shows how
bigquery was able to instantly run
queries and find patterns over these
incoming data what else do you expect
from a modern data warehouse centralized
storage and this is something new with
requiring we already know that big query
can store all of your data and analyze
it but what if we want to read it from
other systems BI tools button stream
processors Hadoop spark machine learning
platforms they should all be able to
read data stores bigquery and we just
announced the bigquery storage API to
enable fast parallel reads without the
need of exporting data first what else
security and Trust to make sure we can
put be put into the hands of our most
sensitive customers Google has developed
features with them like customer manage
encryption keys and access transparency
if anyone managing your cloud data
warehouse had to look at your data you
should know when and why this happened
and you get that with bigquery next data
sharing
you want to make bigquery available to
anyone that needs to analyze data in
your organization on one hand we have a
strong permission model but we also want
to make the power of data accessible to
those who need it so with the query you
can save and share queries as well as
datasets and your analyst can create
beautiful reports with data studio and
third party tools and to make all of
these reports fast and scalable BI
engine is the new plug that acts as a
transparent catch in between and
in-memory database that knows when to
bring data from the bucket when you only
need to decide how much memory you want
it to have and we're making bigquery
increasingly accessible even to users
that would rather do everything in a
spreadsheet and the last bit of a modern
data warehouse predictive
with infinite storage you can know what
happened in the past with real-time
streaming data you can tell what's
happening now and with my children
capabilities you can predict what will
happen next
now bigquery is able to create and run
machine learning models natively inside
yes you can create a model and then use
it to predict within bigquery and only
using a couple simple commands to the
initial linear and logistic regression
models Google cassava k-means clustering
and matrix factorization and even the
ability to import any tensor flow model
you created outside bigquery and even
trained tensor flow models without
leaving your favorite data warehouse
this is our vision of a modern data
warehouse but it doesn't stop here check
the full table to see how one of our
customers put everything together to
power the future driverless cars that's
it for now if you'd like to see the pool
table check out the link in the
description below now it's your turn to
try bigquery I'm Felipe Hoffa and
remember to subscribe
[Music]